[Music]  amazon  but not like your sisters stronger hmm  ah my son  oh this one will be mine  i belong to no one  [Music]  so begins the end  for dark time  i've never seen a being as strong  maybe one  is back  [Music]  i spent a lot of time trying to divide  us  i made a promise to him on his grave  [Music]  i need to bring us together  there are enemies coming from far away  they serve an old power  this world is divided  no protectives here no lanterns  no kleptonium it will fall  in his name  i have turned worlds to dust  all of existence shall be  mine  [Music]  i have a second chance i am not gonna  waste it  he said the age of heroes would never  come again  fighting the devil in his army  [Music]  you know i don't care how many demons  has fallen how many hells  he's never fought us united  it's time to stand  [Music]  fight  the time  is now  you